all right here we go into captain
america the winter soldier we'll be back
to talk about it as soon as we get out
i am here again with paul scavito and
brian daly we just got back from seeing
captain america the winter soldier and
uh first impressions guys
um
i'm gonna say just right out of the gate
coming out of the theater it's my
favorite of the marvel studios films um
i liked it more than the avengers more
than the original captain america more
than any of the iron man or thor movies
um i really enjoyed it i thought it was
a lot of fun to watch i still consider
the original captain america to be my
personal favorite out of the marvel
universe
movies but
this was
this is an incredible movie um on its
own so yeah i
for me it probably won't take the top
spot that'll still be avengers but it's
it's right now in my head it's battling
with the first iron man
um
and what what i think was just really
good about it and really shows that
marvel is headed in a very smart
direction with these franchises is the
fact that it was what you talked about
ryan when we when we talked about the
marvel cinematic universe in general
which is that it is a political thriller
you wouldn't necessarily it is a
superhero movie but it's not just that
right it it fits into this other genre
and it's a genre that
you couldn't tell with the other heroes
cat you can tell a political thriller
with captain america you you couldn't
tell that story with iron man so they're
they've made something
totally more unique to this specific
character which i think shows a really
good um
plan that marvel has for how to move
forward with these franchises
and one of the things that really really
impressed me about the film was how well
it juggled a large cast of characters um
the avengers was obviously an ensemble
picture dealing with six to seven
different heroes um this one is probably
second second up there in terms of how
well it handled different heroes he had
captain america obviously he's the
driving force he is the star
but
mvp awards could be thrown out to black
widow who has a lot of time in the
spotlight and a lot of great moments um
the falcon who we see
develop kind of gets his own little
miniature origin in the story and has a
lot of great moments nick fury
for the time that he is in the film does
a lot of really great stuff and then
multiple different villainous characters
that that it handles well kind of dips
into they all have a spotlight moment or
two so right and which you know i think
is going to lead to the discussion of
sort of
you know whose movie is this is it a
captain america's movie or is it shields
right or
um you know black widows focus um
we get a lot of screen time
we do um
whoops
yeah that all right
um okay but a question that i would ask
has to do actually with the title
should this movie have been called the
winter soldier
right was that that's one of the few
criticisms i mean like the winter
soldier is the punchy title but the
winter soldier as much as he is
important to what's going on and he's
recurring throughout right he's not the
linchpin to what's going on no um on a
on an emotional level he is for the
heroes yeah he does her but even then
it's not until maybe the third act of
the film that that really becomes
yeah a true emotional
i don't want to belittle the character
because he's done very well i think but
at the same time in terms of
plot
just talking plot taking the emotional
right right right payoff but just
talking plot you could sub out
he could have he could have been saved
for the third movie
any number of
super power equivalent characters and
the story would not have changed rushed
right right you could have done you
could have done crossbones as that that
sort of assassin character and fit that
in there
um yeah there were a few other villains
you could have spent more time with the
winter soldier and made him the big bad
of the third movie
but again the when i was watching it i
liked every scene with him i'd like to
oh yeah
there was never a moment where i thought
he was
i mean i think maybe he was being wasted
at times but right i mean if anything
the criticism is on the subtitle yeah
right
not not a misuse of the winter soldier
character yeah that's the it's not that
the character was misused that it was
possibly misleading to put the winter
soldier as part of the title sure i
think that's fair um but
all in all heck of a good time
it was it was an excellent movie and and
i think that's probably going to be it
for this one and and i hope you'll tune
in when we do our spoiler-filled talk
about the implications of a lot of what
happened which will probably be much
much longer so i hope you tune back in
until until then this council is
adjourned